good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday it is
the middle of the week it's hump day
such an important day to commemorate
here at the toast and Nationwide
honestly globally goal yeah why limit
ourselves to just the states no I think
the whole world should be commemorating
hump day oh the camera's coming out for
a global Affair all right that's what
hump day is a global Affair yep
how's your hump day so far you know what
so far it's better than my Tuesday
that's good for a number of reasons I
got to sleep until my normal hour this
morning and I'm wearing a cardigan that
I love from a sister that I love yeah
I've got these new maternity jeans on I
I like my outfit so fabulous to feel
that way because I like it so I'm
feeling really hopeful and excited wow
it's also Wednesday which means it's the
Vanderpump Rules finale and honestly
like I'm [__] ready no it's like it
might as well be on my Google Calendar
the way that I've like scheduled for
this like oh I can't go out to dinner
tonight I just realized I have an event
tonight but I heard you have an event
tonight yeah it's at seven I heard about
it for Margo yeah that you guys are
going to an event
yes without me you're more than welcome
to come but like now I'm thinking what
time is better propose on nine okay I'll
be home by 8 30. like I
I have to get out of there in time I
forgot about that you have to watch the
other episode then before you go I do
your big plan oh but back to back I have
something to share with you that I found
extremely interesting okay I actually
took a picture of it so I finished
Andy's book last night and it was great
like I gave it four out of five stars I
don't know if you necessarily needed to
write another book there was really
nothing major that happened or a lesson
he learned or whatever
um but on the topic of Meghan Markle I
was really surprised that when we
reported on that thing they didn't
include
she was brought up twice in the book and
the second time was much more
interesting the first time was when they
recorded their podcast episode together
and the second time is when the podcast
episode actually came out Andy was
definitely pissed okay so they basically
sat and chatted for an hour but they cut
it down to 20 minutes because it was
Judd Apatow Trevor Noah everyone got 20
minutes and he actually said they had
like a really nice chat over that hour
and then they chatted afterwards just
like gossiping he wouldn't share like
what it was but they really connected
and he was really proud of himself
because he got to throw in like a
question for her about Oprah where she
had basically said we never watched it
and that's why when he quoted were you
silent or silence he was like so proud
of himself she really didn't know what
he was talking about because she didn't
watch it
because she was there when yeah but it
didn't feel like a major moment like it
did to us like it just caught on so when
the episode came out this was his diary
entry Meghan markle's podcast came out
and it was interesting to see how they
produced it she narrates it which is an
effective device especially if you're
cutting an hour down to 20 minutes which
she did however in that narration she
talks about what a tough conversation
this was for her mentioning that she has
conflicting feelings about the
housewives I thought it was interesting
that she said that in narration but
didn't discuss it with me head on
wouldn't that have made for a more
Dynamic conversation she cut out the
Oprah conversation and me saying were
you silent or silenced and left in the
part where she busted me for having
forgotten forgotten meeting her in the
pre-duchess days so like she was shady
and he was pissed like it's actually
um
he's right like it would have been like
an interesting Dynamic conversation she
has conflicting feelings about the
housewives I'm sure in some way as it
pertains to like modern day feminism or
whatever for sure and that's just to me
like such a lame take and I think it's a
bad take I agree Gloria Steinem when she
was on watch Robin's eye being like you
know Housewives is bad for women like
it's not I don't agree with the
low-hanging fruit of takes it's like
saying the Kardashians are bad for women
like I don't think that's true I think
women can handle themselves and if you
look at the housewives and you're
inspired great and if you're a disgusted
great and if you're entertained great
like who [__] cares yeah also like if
you really want to dig into it
Housewives has given a lot of dependent
women Independence not through
traditional means by any means but you
know there's a lot of women who came on
the show who literally were like under
their husband's thumb who are now their
own people yeah no I feel like when
Melissa Gorga was on our podcast for the
first time she was like you should have
seen me like back in the day like such a
housewife in the traditional sense like
literally no money of my own like just
waiting for my husband to come home wipe
the kids out asses and and I think
that's like a lot of The Growing Pains
we see on her in her marriage on the
show like have to do with like this new
journey of her and she was like I meet
so many women who were like we're in the
same so I agree like the whole take on
like being you know is Housewives
controversial for feminism in the modern
woman like I think it's such a bad take
but to like say it in the narration and
then yeah then you'll get the guy you
get the guy who's like creator of this
universe you get him for an interview on
your podcast and you have obviously like
a conflicting feeling and you're not
going to bring it up right and that
would be an interesting conversation and
it's also even if you do feel that way
either say it or don't say it don't say
it when he's not there but have a nice
conversation with him when he is there
so I feel as though actually my takeaway
from the book is him in Meghan Markle
are actually not on good terms
I feel like they're not on bad terms but
they're not on good terms considering
like they did a podcast together I feel
like everyone we've ever podcasted with
like you're on good terms yeah yeah
unless like something happens and you
cut you put in something that you said
and yeah Etc so I did really like the
book
um if you're like a Bravo fan there's
like a lot of interest I'm always just
very interested like what Andy's
relationships with the Housewives Are
personally and I feel like from his
first book to now his last he's gotten
way more comfortable like having actual
friendships with certain women I think
for a while he remained like so
untouchable because he didn't want the
women to compare but he's like so close
with Tamara it's so crazy and so close
with garcelle like I did not see that
because she's like so new to the
universe but I think he just really
likes her and they have like a real
friendship like they talk on the phone
all the time and it's just interesting
that is interesting well I'm glad you
read it thank you for keeping us abreast
yeah it's a good book like it's it's not
gonna change your life but like it's
good that's okay it doesn't have to no a
great Beach read like it really there
were a couple times where like I
genuinely like cackled like he's very
funny great yeah I also found it
interesting like he um is really
comfortable like sharing moments where
he's acting like a diva [__] celebrity
like screaming at people or like waiting
in line and being impatient like and he
like just kind of owns those moments I
feel like
I would be surprised like you know you
you think he would get like [__] for
that you know yeah but maybe he's just
trying to get out ahead of it maybe like
this was actually a crazy moment where
he was in DC and he went to that
um Hotel bar that Chris Candace's
husband from Potomac is the manager of
okay and so we went there hey because
he's heard it's a good spot and B he
thought you know he'd get like VIP
treatment turns out his uh her husband
had recently been like you know let go
or
left the the job but he still went and
like they couldn't find a place to stand
and they finally found a place to stand
at this packed bar and this like manager
or like Hostess comes over and like
yells at them and Andy was just like and
he had it and he snapped and then
security came and escorted him and said
that the hostess is crying and it was
just like this crazy Saga where like he
yelled at this girl and like the girl
was like obviously like overtly
sensitive but Andy like totally owned
the fact that he made the girl crying
like it ruined his whole week
yeah well I feel like a situation like
that is so that if that story ever like
gets out he's like yeah no
felt bad about it I barely accepted yeah
accountability yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was very introspective it was good
but it's crazy that that doesn't like
make it to dumois well so then he did
bring up Dumas he was like I was in the
Hampton James corden's eggs our front
page right right okay so he was in the
Hamptons and he was at this coffee shop
that was taking forever he like just got
a t I think he was sick and he's just
like oh my God he was like pacing he was
like I looked like a lunatic like
talking to myself just like wondering
when my teeth was gonna come and he
eventually stormed out without the T
because it was a six dollar T and he
never it never came whatever
and it ended up on June 1 not that he
was like being an [__] just that he
appeared to be in a rush and left
without his tea
that's a nice spin yeah it was pretty
good for him yeah
um so yeah that was what I've done very
nice yesterday I was just like you know
what like [__] this I was not in the
[__] mood to answer an email to
put one ounce of work in I sat down at
two o'clock after the toast and I was
like [__] it and I just read the whole
day I was just like feeling I was kind
of feeling like playing hooky you were
just like turning to literature I forgot
to lead I forgot that I could play hooky
you know yeah like it's kind of fun yeah
I loved it I'm happy for you I was taken
down by my tiredness and my allergies
yesterday everyone's talking about the
allergies the allergies they're not good
we were in the park
and it was just a lot of pollen like
pollen falling everywhere so sorry yeah
but it was okay other than that it was a
nice day and then I went out to dinner
and I did not see Taylor Swift well I
figured if you did when I would know at
this point into like that's what you
would lead with but how was your
adventures in spotting Taylor Swift
going what's the plan for the rest of
the week yesterday was like your big
opportunity yeah okay so let me tell you
how yesterday like I got played I went I
chose a hot spot for dinner I kept my
eyes on alert and I would say 20 minutes
into my meal guess who walks in I know
the answer so Gigi Hadid right so I was
like oh my God my plan is working
Taylor's obviously coming to meet her I
thought I was feeling on top of the
world I was so like feeling not present
in my dinner because I just had like my
eyes and ears open to the to the
restaurant and then you know days turned
into nights and nights turned into
months and Taylor never showed up
and according to my research Taylor
didn't leave the house last night which
I guess is almost better than like if I
chose the wrong restaurant you know yeah
so
yeah
are you gonna keep trying to go back to
that place like for the rest of the week
because she probably will go there one
night this week
I just can't we just have to watch
Phantom pearls right right tonight's a
wash I have an engagement party tomorrow
night Uptown Taylor's not gonna be
Uptown so I just feel like I tried okay
I got dressed and I stayed alert
and nothing came of it it's only
Wednesday lemon it's only Wednesday
lemon it's only Wednesday I'm like why
are you calling me lemon but I get it
um like you literally got dressed in
state alert one night when you went to
dinner No I gave it a shot like that's
what I'm saying like I'm not this is not
gonna be like I'm not gonna scavenge
like it's fine and maybe like you you'll
stay alert but not dressed so you could
just if someone says oh my God Taylor's
at so and so you run no
no it has to be like I have to be there
you know it has to be like meant to be
okay
it's okay I feel like I gave it a
triumphant attempt
and I'm okay with that okay I'm glad I'm
I'm okay with that too then I'm not
gonna pressure you thanks I'd like to
like you should work like take care of
yourself right right I could be like
running out of the house pulling my hair
out every night when I hear Taylor's on
14th Street you know yeah
think of the the Ubers I'll spend money
on the traffic traffic I'll end up
pulling my hair out
and that would be bad and I don't have a
lot of hair to spare these days
um it's also Wednesday which means it's
your toasters we've got three great
submissions from girlies who need it
they need us Jacks and we're here for
you we're always here for you but
especially on Wednesdays yeah I wouldn't
say we're always here for you no meeting
we're here for you on Wednesdays yeah
that's where you can find us so see your
toasters gmail.com so I think without
further Ado is it yeah we actually have
really good stories today and I'm really
excited to chit chat with my girl a
swirly turdy yep without further Ado
here are the fast type stories that I'm
going to chit chat with my girly swirly
turdy about that you need to know this
morning thanks Jax today's episode is
brought to you by Court Furniture life
is always changing your furniture should
be able to change with it with court
furniture rental you can get the
furniture and services that you need to
help make every life transition as
seamless as possible whether you're
making a short-term long distance a
short-term long-distance move relocating
starting a new chapter or you simply
just don't want to be tied down to
owning Furniture court has a solution
for you simply pick the furniture you
want then their expert team delivers it
and sets it up the furniture will be
there when you need it and gone when you
don't get furniture on your own terms
with court Furniture rentals you can
visit court.com podcast to learn more
and find the furniture package that fits
your fits your life so true be being an
owner of furniture it's just like
so like you're so tied down yeah you
can't live a spontaneous Carefree
lifestyle no it's such a commitment it's
such a commitment like who is the space
the storage like all that court gets rid
of all of those things Styles change
Trends change that's another thing and
they really have beautiful pieces
Apartments change then you're stuck with
this L-shaped couch right and it's like
what if my new living room can
accommodate an L-shaped couch with court
you don't have to worry about that you
press play whenever and wherever you
want with core furniture rental you rent
Furniture when you need it and return it
when you don't they take care of all of
the hassle all of the logistics all of
the boring stuff so again visit
court.com podcast that's
c-o-r-t.com to learn more and find the
furniture package that fits your needs
court.com
c-o-r-t.com slash podcast make room for
something new without leaving a mess
behind to clean up they'll pick up what
you've rented without lifting a finger
and by renting you're supporting a
sustainable way of living hmm today's
episode is also brought to you by game
time buying tickets to your favorite
events should not be stressful and I
feel like these days it's always like a
rat race a hamster wheel anxiety
inducing but with game time it's not
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and theater near you with killer
deals on last minute tickets and their
best price guarantee you can stop
stressing over tickets and start getting
hyped for the fun you'll actually have
yeah I feel like these days like we're
not even focusing on the actual
enjoyment the fun of the event we're
just like panicked waiting in queues
game time is a really fabulous app that
ever since I downloaded I find myself
like going to more things I'm like oh
it's Tuesday let me see if Billy Joel is
that Madison Square Garden like it's
just that the fact that you have it and
they make it so stress-free you'll find
yourself going to more events
spontaneous yeah
just like a gal who can throw caution to
the wind and like go see Simple Plan
this weekend or something yes to life
exactly if you're in you're saying yes
to life era game time is an absolute
necessity
so game time is the place for last
minute ticket deals forget planning
months in advance game time is deals on
tickets right up to the day of the event
you get exclusive oh the truckers for
game time get exclusive Flash Deals on
tickets for football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater and more you
know while the Knicks were still in the
playoffs game time was an indispensable
resource for Ben he got a lot of his
tickets from game time Unfortunately
they are no longer in but that doesn't
diminish the important role game time
played in Ben's life so download the
game time app create an account and use
code toast for 20 off your purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code toast at for 20 off on the
game time app download game time today
at last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed thank you Claudia you're
welcome now our first story is a tragedy
the new photos it's a tragedy the new
photos for it ends with us the Colleen
Hoover book turned movie have dropped we
see Blake Lively fully transformed as
redhead lily bloom and fans are pissed
so if you've seen these photos because
they're all over the internet if you
haven't seen just Google you know they
were Paparazzi down the street we saw a
lot Ryle who was played by Justin
baldoni we saw Lily played by big Lively
in character so it was the first time
we're seeing her in wardrobe in hair she
has red hair
and it's giving Brave
it's tragic uh The Outfits the hair it
is to say the least
shocking it's shocking and it's
offensive to the fans it's offensive to
the book too and it's offensive to Blake
Lively like the most stylish woman on
the planet who would put her in these
clown outfits I mean that big brown
dress the socks and the shoes
the bag the shirt tied at the top yeah
no honestly it felt like a prank every
item is bad worse than the next there's
not like a coat that ties it together
and I have to say I don't remember Lily
Bloom as being a freak that's no no she
was like this like really kind of cute
gardeny like girly girly yeah no it's so
shocking and I will say like whenever a
book turns into a movie there's you know
people are hyper sensitive they're
always on alert they're criticizing and
I feel like a lot of the times it's
unfair like whenever photos come out
people you know I disagree this is so
[__] Next Level I don't feel like
when photos come out of a movie turning
of a book turning into a movie that we
are usually disheartened like when we
saw a Mila Kunis so I was gonna bring
that up too because that was very
exciting she's like walking down the
street and just and it was a regular
dress you know but like people who are
so obsessed with a certain book like
they're always going to be sensitive and
like I can understand that and I just
want to say the backlash to these photos
that is not bad that is not that no this
is warranted this I was shocked I mean I
don't know what's worse the hair or the
clothes probably the clothes but what's
with the hair I don't know why what's
that girl's name from Brave
I'll Google it no it's like not
something it's like a weird name yeah
not weird but it's like not uh common
like it's like something from um
Paul dark
it's Scottish yeah exactly yeah sorry I
didn't mean weird Scottish I wasn't like
trying to be offensive
um what the [__] is her name
what is it
Marita yes that's not what I was
thinking yes
Merida whatever Merida I was thinking
like demelza from poldar because the
hair is giving to melza too it's giving
morelda what do we say her name Merida
Merida why literally why is why is it
like that I don't know like such a weird
take it's it's
offensive to everyone it's offensive to
the readers it's offensive to Colleen
it's offensive to Blake it's offensive
to redheads it's offensive to Blake like
and she's such a stylish Queen like she
knows that what she's she's just when
you're an actor like you're just an
actor you do what you're told you know
I don't blame Blake I don't know who the
[__] I'm blaming uh wardrobe but also
someone at the top has decided to ruin
this movie yes maybe like someone at the
top is like old high school friends with
Colleen Hoover's March Nemesis and is
like I'm gonna take her book and I'm
gonna ruin it I'm taking the Hoovers
down lit I don't know if Colleen knows
that this is happening she's being set
up and I feel like she just is so
immensely grateful for all these
opportunities because you can see that
like sometimes something like seems
really great but it's compromising the
Integrity of your work I know and I'm
just so confused because you know the
casting wasn't what we had hoped but
that doesn't mean that there's no hope
for this Lively is like an amazing
gorgeous actress that we love to see on
the screen so you know what so they went
with the Stars we'll deal with it when
people thought maybe they should have
went with a young undiscovered Talent
maybe she wasn't the age range we
thought whatever like none of it was not
I'll never be like mad about seeing
Blake Lively no and none of the casting
was really like something they couldn't
come back from yeah these were all
professional hired actors like they can
make a movie but I don't know what I'm
seeing now I don't know it's sabotage
it's so like let's just call this way to
Spade like those clothes were fugly like
what the [__]
fugly she's a girl if you read the book
she like she looks like she's on the set
of Little Women yes yes if you read the
book you know like Lily the character
like loves flowers she loves beautiful
things she would dress in like pastel
colors and like you know beautiful
bright
materials like what is this Duty brown
dress from what I remember about the
book like her wardrobe wasn't uh a
factor a factor at all so she probably
like wore jeans and a t-shirt like shop
did Zara so true she's not her wardrobe
is not a camera model like this is
[__] distracting it's destructive
I was literally like guthawed I keep
I've been using that word for like three
weeks is that even the right word yeah
oh I was absolutely flabbergasted and
defaud like I was shook when I saw it
I'm like there's no way I'm like maybe
this is her you know break clothes like
maybe she's on break and she's wearing a
big Duty brown dress maybe but then also
the dress gets a t-shirt put on top yes
with a knot at some point and the
T-shirt says like Earhart
I don't know with a knot in it and then
a painter's Smock on top
it's
really bad the hair is bad everything is
bad
yeah I'm just I'm really
I'm shocked
and I often think like when there's like
Universal backlash like people are being
dramatic they're not no honestly they're
not being dramatic enough no they're not
especially this book has such a cult
following like if you search it on
Tumblr like there's so many fan edits
like the movie produces itself like the
channels are there it's really not that
hard it's not like you have to create
like the world of Hogwarts like it's
just a couple of good looking people in
an apartment in Boston yeah with flowers
Right Flowers that's it true and you
chose this it doesn't need like a
different creative lens it doesn't need
uh what's that woman's name from Sex in
the City Patricia Fields it doesn't need
like the Wardrobe is not a factor no
it's really not it's just regular people
with regular jobs you don't need to
recreate the wheel you just need to let
the story tell itself yeah it's bad
we'll keep you updated this like the
every time something comes out about
this movie it's like worse than the next
I don't know what we're gonna hear next
but I'm scared I know I'm scared are you
ready for our next story yeah which is
some good hair news oh yeah Beyonce
tease is a new hair care launch she said
she can't wait for you to experience
what she's been creating so Beyonce took
to Instagram on Tuesday less than a week
after kicking out her kicking off her
tour yeah
to tease the launch of her new hair care
line so the first photo in the carousel
was of her posing in a mirror while
style styling her natural curls and then
the second picture was a throwback photo
of her getting her hair braided in a
salon chair then she had the third photo
as like a statement written for her how
many of y'all knew my first job was
sweeping hair in my mama's Salon
Destiny's Child got our start by
performing for clients while they were
getting their hair done she said I was
exposed to so many different kinds of
entrepreneurial women in her Salon I saw
firsthand how the ways we nurture and
celebrate hair can directly impact our
souls I watched her heal and be of
service to so many women having learned
so much on my hair Journey I've always
dreamed of carrying on her Legacy she
ended the note with an exciting message
saying how she can't wait for you to
experience what she's been creating with
her first initial and a heart so so cute
hair by Beyonce here by Beyonce I feel
like based on the letter and then the
visuals it's like going to be targeted
for black hair which honestly like I
feel like Beyonce is going to become
like a billionaire five times over like
this is the best idea yeah I wasn't
didn't before yesterday like thinking
like what business does Beyonce need to
get into she should get into the like
Beauty game just like you know how
everyone else is doing but this is a
no-brainer yeah no and I think a lot of
times when celebrities announce like a
hair or a bacon or makeup it feels like
very cash grabby and like dumb but this
feels like extremely on brand I think
like so many girls look up to Beyonce
and like style their hair up to Beyonce
so I think this is a great idea I saw
the craziest Tick Tock of Beyonce's mom
okay somehow she was at one of the
concerts she got like stuck in GA she's
like literally behind the barricades
like with people and she's trying to
she's talking to security and like
literary security like like literally
people the people behind the barricade
and Security in front of the barricade
like hoist her up in the air and like
put her over the barricade she like got
lost at the concert that's crazy before
the concert had begun but I'm glad the
security recognized her and like didn't
make her
yeah thank God she's like like a person
of a public knowledge you know yeah
people are like this is Beyonce's mom
how did she get stuck I don't know she
honestly looked hilarious like she would
be like a funny gal that's really funny
um I hope we get more info on this soon
I know like let's let's brainstorm names
hmm
believe
it's obviously gonna have like a b in it
it's gonna have you're right about that
and did I hear she's closing down Ivy
Park I didn't hear that I think I did oh
interesting which I feel like was really
never like it never felt like the right
business to me for her no but I feel
like it did really well while it was
around yeah because people just love
Beyonce but let me see if it wasn't like
the obvious thing Adidas to end clothing
partnership with Beyonce a month ago oh
interesting I didn't feel like it was
like a good business call like when I
think of Beyonce I don't think of
athleisure
um
it was cute athleisure like as an
athleisure company on its own like fine
it was yeah whatever I don't know it
just didn't feel like a match like this
is a much better suited business for
Beyonce in my opinion I wonder well
first of all we could also look to like
song titles for perhaps inspiration it's
a good call or like song lyrics
Renaissance hair oh that's pretty cool
yeah but there's no B in it no no but
there might not be a b if it's like an
iconic Beyonce yeah lyric or reference
yeah yeah oh
like the Becky with the good hair no she
would never she would never I'm not
Becky with the good hair but just like
good hair by Beyonce I kind of love that
good hair by Beyonce
but I think in that lyric good hair
I think
I don't know actually the good hair like
whatever it meant yeah yeah yeah it good
hair is like good hair it's still too
we'll get up in the dictionary yes hair
that is good right
good that is hair yeah yeah yeah good
hair is actually like not a bad name no
not at all
and obviously since she's like teasing
it I think it's probably like ready to
go I would hope so it's not like you
know years away I think we're like weeks
away from finding out that's exciting I
love a launch so do I a hard launch this
was something this is extremely soft
yeah but exciting nonetheless exciting
nonetheless
are you ready for our next story yeah
speaking of excitement for speak now TV
Taylor Lautner says that he feels safe
but he's praying for John as the release
for Taylor Swift's third re-recorded
album speak now Taylor's version looms
this summer there's one man with
romantic ties to the singer who feels
confident about revisiting the era ahead
of the drop Taylor Lautner he laughed
when today.com asked how he's dealing
with less than two months before he
along with millions of swifties are set
to revisit 2009 and 2010. at the time
the actor
um was in his
what is this at the time the book
Twilight was at its peak he too was in
the spotlight for his personal life like
just get to the [__] no just say he
was in Twilight thanks
anyways he's back to December on speak
now he said yeah I think it's a great
album yeah I feel safe okay of course
praying for John the swifties know like
Taylor Lautner is the least problematic
ex he's sleeping you know very soundly
at night knowing this album is on its
way no and speak now is to John Mayer
what red was to Taylor Jake Gillum Jake
Gyllenhaal and technically what Fearless
was to Joe Jonas yeah but the thing is
and why it's different it's like there
was no Bloodshed with Joe Jonas because
like a Joe and Taylor are friends and at
the end of the day like Joe didn't do
anything to Taylor like yeah he broke up
with her on the phone but like he didn't
hurt her like he was like you know Jake
Gyllenhaal and John Mayer like we're all
still mad because it's like you were 35
year old men like taking advantage of
this teenager like you're [__]
disgusting like we're not gonna like
just let that go yeah and because it's
the these from what it seems are not
isolated incidents like especially with
Jake Gyllenhaal like there's been like
even his current girlfriend is super
young so much younger than him like it's
a pattern of Behavior so I think that
red Taylor's version coming out just
like highlighted something that has
always been true yeah and I think with
John Mayer he's very he's a problematic
lover in general we've known but I don't
know
I don't know that it's going to be as
bad for him because I feel like
everything about John Mayer is known
like he's very accountable it's actually
so true it was right he's like in his
post-womanizer era he's like
rehabilitated yes so I don't think it's
going to be like as shocking as
realizing like oh my God Jake Gyllenhaal
is like a freaking [__] up yeah no
that's true like we've been knowing yeah
about and he's like been open about it
um how he like took this break from the
spotlight and he's I think watch Happens
Live Like a few times he always refers
to like his past life as like you know
he's a former womanizer yeah so but I
also think that what doug Jake
Gyllenhaal's grave was all too well 10
minute version because then we got like
details that we didn't know before yeah
so it would have to be Vault tracks that
would bury that would add color John
Mayer yeah I mean also with John Mayer
um I think everyone's on high alert
because would have could have should
have from Midnight people
believe is also about John Mayer so it's
like we're we're actually still getting
new information on the on the Saga yeah
so I just think John Mayer will weather
the storm better I feel like he might
even lean into it a little bit whereas
Jake Gyllenhaal like probably won't sit
down for an interview unless you swear
on the Bible that you won't ask about it
yeah no for sure I I think you're right
like um
because John Mayer like has responded he
wrote paper dolls and that was like his
big response years later but then this
year at a concert he performed it and he
gave like a little bit like he spoke
about it before it was nothing crazy was
said but he acknowledged it which was
crazy for the community
um yeah I don't think it'll be like
complete silence from John because I
think he feels confident in the fact
that he's not a bad guy anymore yeah
yeah and he's like he's an open book
whereas like has this like facade facade
of a reputation to uphold so that's
actually like an amazing point so that's
the difference to me I think John will
be fine I I think John will be fine too
because it's also just a part of his
image that's why people like love him
problematic King it's like Jake
Gyllenhaal is supposed to be this like
perfect Hollywood actor with like this
pristine reputation and John is like bad
boy musician and I think for a lot of
people like the more bad things we learn
about him like the more we love him
which is so [__] yeah but I think is
the truth for a lot of his fans
but speak now is younger than red Taylor
yeah she was younger but is John Mayer
younger than Jake Gyllenhaal I honestly
think they're like actually I would
think maybe John but like can I ask you
something John Mayer and until John
Mayer's 45 okay damn
um
John Mayer and Taylor what was the
relationship extent and longevity of
their relationship and Jake is 42. okay
so their relationship if I remember
correctly began as you know
a mutual respect like of course Taylor
knew who John Mayer was and then John
Mayer found out who Taylor was was
really kind of inspired by her
songwriting
um they publicly flirted with each other
like he was very complimentary of her he
was dazzled by her
um and then I think they worked together
to write a song half of my heart oh
that's the song I think he performed
when he spoke on tour about Taylor not
paper dolls whatever
um and during the creative process you
know they they had a brief but fiery
romance I think Taylor was very excited
about you know the prospect of a much
older much more successful probably one
of her songwriting Heroes he's one of
the greatest songwriters of our time you
know to to show interest in her and he
was like you know oh shiny young thing
and you know to tell us all this time
did they hook up I believe they they
briefly flung
I don't do I don't think they were ever
in like an actual relationship and I
think that was the problem like Chandler
was searching for something real and he
was like [__] around okay so um if
you listen to the lyrics of Dear John it
sounds like he was just kind of like
playing with her emotions and she was
like very you know into the whole thing
okay and here's a crazy question who did
Taylor lose her virginity to
um All Too Well Jake All Too Well is
about the scarf I think a lot of people
believe to be a metaphor for The
Virginity and she also like has a lyric
where she like pretty much explicitly
says
um
I would have to Google it but that's the
vibe that I got which would mean that
like she didn't have sex with John Mayer
because it was before I mean it's
entirely possible because she was like a
conservative Queen yeah yeah but you can
still like have strong feelings yes yes
yes but I I've thought for years like
who did Taylor lose her virginity which
is like a disgusting thing to think I
guess but John Mayer
it's a weird question but like I feel
like in the context of the conversation
it's your main because Dear John really
sounds like the song of a girl who just
lost her virginity and so for a long
time I thought she lost her virginity to
John Mayer and then the floating theory
that would be like really messed up yeah
but then the floating theory was that
like all too well the scarf was like a
symbol of of The Virginity and like
Maggie Gyllenhaal actually doesn't have
it she actually just lost her virginity
at Maggie Gyllenhaal's house and so her
virginity is at Maggie Gillen Hall's
house and she can't get it back right
right and then when Taylor was doing
press for the All Too Well 10 minute
versions she had been asked by a
reporter if if the scarf could be a
metaphor and she said yes interesting so
yeah when people ask the right questions
like no like them asking Taylor Lautner
about things about this okay just pulled
up the lyrics because I would love to
find the lyrics to find the lyric that
I'm referring to
because it reminds you of innocence and
it smells like me like that's
innocence's virginity yeah yeah
but then also there's really an argument
to be made that John Mayer took her
virginity like especially would have
could have should have
God rest my soul I miss who I used to be
the two of my own clothes and a lot of
them could have would have should have
listened to me this is important a lot
of the Coulda Woulda Shut Up lyrics it's
uh feel religious they have like
religious elements to it and you know
she grew up like very conservative when
you lose your virginity there's like a
element of like religious shame to it so
the stained glass stained glass windows
in my mind I regret you all the time I
can't let this go I fight with you in my
sleep the tomb won't close very
religious keep on waiting for a sign and
then it's if Clarity is in depth then
why won't this die
um
Living For The Living For The Thrill of
hitting you where it hurts give me back
my girlhood it was mine first that
really feels like a lyric about
virginity
oh
and cloaked in this song with like
religious references it feels why do
people think it's about John
it says 19. and he said when she's
when she talks about being 19 Dear John
when she starts by being 19 it is John
Mayer she's letting us know
okay okay hold on let me find what I'm
looking for something about the lifeless
there really is an argument in terms of
lyrics to be made about either men
taking her virginity and I don't know if
this conversation like speculating on
someone's virginity is like really
disgusting and inappropriate because it
kind of feels gross it does
um so I apologize Taylor like this is
really not cool but like I'm just
curious at least we can take solace
knowing she doesn't listen so true
ugh Why can't I find what I'm looking
for what are you looking for maybe like
when she said something about like her
like in all too well in all too well
like her life like her body like laying
there like like
I don't know not a crumpled up piece of
paper
drop in the comments who do you think it
was yeah that oh my God that's crazy
I really don't know
like honestly you found it and then you
wondered where it went to as I reach for
you but all I felt was shame and felt my
life was my life was great that I just
feel like that's kind of like how you
feel when you lose your virginity to the
wrong person a hundred percent
arguments TV8 on both sides I really
felt also a lot of speculation on all
sides yeah I really feel I could have
would have should have like is the song
about losing your virginity too I'll
have to listen with that in mind yeah I
mean give me back my girl girlhood is
already a thesaurus synonym for
virginity but also now all too well I
associate it so closely with the book my
dark Vanessa I told you this thing
before which is about like a a young
girl who like has an affair with her
teacher so I might be like conflating
like what that story means yeah yeah
with this you're projecting I'm
projecting yeah yeah yeah that's
possible but I think it the the the more
in terms of things Taylor has actually
confirmed she did confirm like the scarf
is metaphoric
so I do think it's Jake Gyllenhaal okay
so
yeah
great and also like Taylor would have
been underage right with John Mayer 19.
oh yeah no sorry
this episode is brought to you by
vegamore we're always trying to do right
by our body so when it comes to our
scalp and scalp Health finding a product
that actually works and is made with
clean ingredients always seems like a
trade-off but with vagamore we get
products that are made with clean
ingredients and give us visibly healthy
hair and scalp so everyone knows like
I'm kind of like in my bald era it's
really been tough I know I'm choosing to
say I'm in my regrowth era I love that
with vegamore we're seeing visibly
thicker fuller shinier longer hair
without the harsh ingredients all
vegamore products are 100 cruelty free
they're never formulated with
potentially harmful chemicals like power
bins or home hormones so their grow
Essentials kit comes with shampoo
conditioner a serum I love this serum I
like put it in my hair and just chill
for a while
um because I'm doing a lot of things for
my for my regrowth era and I feel like
obviously I'm taking vitamins and stuff
but I also like actually putting
something like on the hair it just feels
like it makes sense and the gross
theorem came highly recommended by a lot
of you guys I'm really enjoying the
process I like that it's totally cruelty
free it's not made with hormones or
power bins and of course you're in your
clean girl era so with the jam shampoo
and conditioner I love the shampoo and
conditioner I swapped maybe six months
ago
um I realized that my other shampoo and
conditioner had perfumes fragrances
which are no bueno and I love the vague
more shampoo conditioner it does
sometimes feel like if you want to use
clean products you have to sacrifice
quality not in this situation give
yourself the hair you never thought you
could have with bigamora for a limited
time toast listeners get 20 off their
first order by going to vegamore.com
toast and using Code toast at checkout
that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 off your first order
vegamore.com toast code toast today's
episode is also brought to you by the
farmer's dog because strice Bros deserve
nothing but the best when you look at
bags of dog food you'll see pictures of
bright carrots and juicy steaks but then
you open the bag and you're getting
burnt little pellets dog food needs some
fresh thinking eating processed food for
every meal is not healthy we all know
that and kibble is subject to multiple
rounds of high heat processing so it
makes it an ultra processed food why
don't you try something fresh like the
farmer dog it's real food feeding your
food the farmer's dog is real fresh
healthy food with whole meat and
vegetables it's gently cooked in human
grade kitchens and it preserves the
nutritional value of the food so Theo
has been in his fresh food era for a
while now his breath is so much better
oh my God I thought just like all dogs
had like vile disgusting breath no like
Theo needed to be like like a change in
his diet his breath is so much better he
has like so much more energy really kind
of consistent firm poops sorry not to be
gross his coat is really shiny there's a
lot of health benefits but the breath
thing is really enough for me to switch
um meals arrive in pre-portioned ready
to serve packs it's conveniently
delivered on your schedule dog people
all across the country have ordered
millions of meals from the farmer's dog
it's never been easier to invest in your
dog's health with fresh food give 50 off
your first box of fresh healthy food at
the farmersdog.com toast that's 50 if
you've been wanting to make the switch
to fresh healthy dog food it's a real
good investment in your dog's health it
has so many health benefits now is maybe
the sign that you need you also get free
shipping when you go to the
farmersdog.com toast again that's the
farmersdog.com toast for 50 off your
first box and the free shipping thank
you you're welcome are you ready for our
next story I really need to get your
take on it yeah because I don't know how
to feel you really need to get my tape I
feel so special I need to like flush it
out with you like so you need me to help
you come up with your take yeah I
sometimes feel that yeah yeah Disney's
new Little Mermaid seems to contain a
dig at Kate Middleton
what yeah I read that I skipped the
headline a few times before I clicked
and I was like okay let me see if it's
compelling if there's anything here
because also like Megan has been known
to say like she felt like Arielle and
the little mermaid she said that on
Oprah it's like one of her favorite
movies oh I don't remember that okay
yeah a reviewer who saw an early
screening of Disney's new remake of The
Little Mermaid tells page six that it
seems to dip a toe into the megsit
debacle and even contains what appears
to be a dig at Kate Middleton the critic
tells page six that the film seems to
draw a number of subtle yet plausible
comparisons between Meghan Markle and
Prince Harry on the one hand and the two
lead characters Arielle who is play who
is black in the new version and Prince
Eric who is white on the other hand so
that's one but one scene in particular
seems to get pretty literal quote Ariel
has sacrificed her voice in order to get
to the surface and meet Prince Eric she
can't speak so he tries to guess her
name they said
quote his first guest is Diana
his second guess is Catherine but after
Ariel gives a disgusted reaction he
concludes okay definitely not Catherine
huh
that does feel
that doesn't feel like a threat it
doesn't feel random the Spy says there's
nothing in the movie's internal logic to
otherwise explain the mermaid's extreme
response to the name Catherine
um Disney would be disingenuous to imply
those names were coincidental this
person said I agree like you have to
choose of all the names and all the land
you choose Diana and Kate right and
meanwhile in her 2021 interview with
Oprah Megan herself said that she
identified with Arya from The Little
Mermaid she recalled watching the movie
during her troubled time in the UK and
she said I went oh my God she falls in
love with the prince and because of that
she loses her voice you see Meghan
Markle out last night I did which we'll
talk about it shook stunning with this
you know she just gets better like
better looking and he is really not cute
anymore
she looked amazing he did not look nice
they look like a mismatch like he looks
like slobish with his like tie loose I
thought his outfit was really bad yeah
and which like he he's just like not
like he's just like aging like
honestly like barely looked at his face
because like he's so nothing important
no it's like I'm not gonna critique
someone's face like Fair what can you do
about it
whatever but I thought his outfit was
just Slavic
not tailored next to that dress and she
oh she just looked Next Level yeah um
okay but back to this it definitely
feels like 100 like a nod maybe it was
just like Disney and you know Megan does
like work with Disney she does voice
over work she's like a big partnership
with them it might have just been like a
nod like you saw us and we see you like
it doesn't necessarily feel like like a
dig at Kate but more so a nod to Megan
that's how I'll choose to see it yes
except for the fact that it's a literal
dig at Kate and that there's no Megan
element you know like I do also think
like the names that they chose like
choosing Diana like is weird yeah like
not not like oh it's you know it's a
it's not a coincidence I just think it's
like weird to bring up someone's dead
mother-in-law like
yeah unless it's an odd does Prince Eric
know she oh no she's not is she a
princess she's becoming kind of
unfamiliar so what I was gonna do with
this story what I was gonna say is I
have not seen a little mermaid in ages
I'll probably see the new one so I
really I need to see the movie because I
don't remember the plot like whatsoever
and B I need to see the scene for myself
in order to come up with like a full
thought but for right now I'm thinking
yeah it's definitely a nod to Megan it's
a little shady
I'm not really feeling it as like I
guess because she makes like a gross
face but yeah I don't know I don't know
and I feel like it sounds like they said
Camilla you know right like Catherine is
Kate is really beloved like yeah
not that Camilla deserves hate no no no
you know she's a little more
controversial yeah no there's like more
of an argument to be made yeah
I don't know but I'm gonna say like
Elizabeth
not make a face but like these are
queenly names right right of Queens
princesses yeah there's so much hype for
this movie it's crazy I feel like we've
been talking about it forever yeah
hmm when does it come out I don't know I
thought it was already out no this is
like only one person saw it right it's
been under like lock and key yeah
there's a lot of hoopla hopefully
they're not lying about what they saw
and like getting us in a tizzy for
nothing no way they wouldn't do that but
I just think it's interesting me too our
fifth and final story The Bachelor
announces their first ever senior
citizen season ABC has finally announced
that the bachelor nation is welcoming
another spin-off this time its
contestants will be senior citizens
called the Golden bachelor which will
Premiere this fall it will focus on one
lucky older gentleman and
age-appropriate female suitors who will
compete for his love in a press release
the new reality series is described as a
whole new kind of Love Story one for the
golden years the network describes the
salt and peppered hair twinkly-eyed
mature gentleman as a hopeless romantic
who will be given a second chance at
love in the search for a partner with
whom to share the sunset years of life
per the release the group of women
arriving at the Mansion have a lifetime
of experience living through love loss
and laughter hoping for a spark that
ignites a future full of endless
possibilities
honestly just like knowing what we know
about how like producers and production
like treat contestants like the thought
of these like Precious young I mean not
young sorry precious older women like
being subjected to like all night Rose
ceremonies and like you know
manipulation honestly I'm so this feels
like elder abuse wow that was not gonna
be my take maybe I just you know am
believing the Press hype I thought it
sounded so beautiful and also
interesting like just older people are
just more interesting and smarter than I
agree with people and like I actually
feel like
a a real love match could come from this
like you really know yourself at that
age but you're looking for like what you
need at this stage of your life like I I
believe in the process here
but all night Rose ceremonies is elder
abuse so I actually do agree like
conceptually this isn't the worst idea
for a show but I just have no faith in
the production company that produces a
bachelor whoever it is like they stink
at everything if this show had been on
Netflix and they did like a real
experiment I would trust it more like
the idea isn't bad but I have no faith
in anything that airs on ABC honestly
that's a good point I'm sure if it was
on Netflix it would be very good and the
elders would be taken care of I kind of
like the idea of them doing like typical
Bachelor things yeah like dates yeah and
how like kind of corny it is and I am
going to be hopeful about this are you
gonna watch
depends on where I'm at in my life right
I'm open to it yeah I would sooner watch
that than the next season of The
Bachelor oh my God in an instant it
should be called the grachler the great
great gratchler you know like the the
grandparents Bachelor I got it the
grouchler so brief programming update is
that there's a jackhammer outside our
window and we want to be able to give
our like full-time attention and love to
Deer toasters we're gonna do deer
toasters tomorrow yeah so that you know
quiet and peaceful environment so we can
mull over your quandary and not have
like a jackhammer in my brain that's
like the worst it's hard to give advice
with a jackhammer in your brain so I'm
so sorry to like cut this episode short
today but it's not our fault the
[__] jackhammers outside so
thanks so much for listening to the
toast Monday Morning Show we took the
Thousand stories on YouTube you're
watching this on YouTube please
subscribe give this video thumbs up
Russell available
videos
love ya bye love ya bye